bientôt 20 heures vous vous demandez si
vous aurez le droit d'être dehors avant
5 heures du matin oui
pour toutes ces raisons là vous partez
exercer votre métier considéré comme
essentiel où vous en revenez
même chose pour les cours du soir qui
ont lieu physiquement si vous êtes un
professionnel de santé ou que vous ont
consulté un là aussi c'est permis pad
amende non plus si vous êtes en transit
pour un voyage longue distance il n'y
aura pas d'attestation du gouvernement
pour circuler seulement ce modèle
d'autorisation à destination des
employeurs mais une convocation
administrative peut tout aussi bien vous
servir pour justifier votre présence
hors du domicile et un parent ou un
aidant qui accompagne une personne pour
des raisons médicales ou de garde
partagé exception là aussi la raison la
plus visible pour justifier une sortie
ça reste le chien une heure de promenade
permise autour du domicile
évidemment il faut être accompagné de
son chien pour pouvoir se prévaloir de
cette exception locke ce qu'ils
promènent leurs chats ne sont pas
concernés et au delà du couvre feu le
nouveau confinement contient quelques
subtilités
contrairement au printemps les visites
de propriété sont autorisés pour les
transactions immobilières
pour lutter contre l' isolement une
personne seule peut rendre visite à une
autre personne seule mais toujours la
même
seuls les résidents des ch à celle des
ont le droit de voir deux et dans
différents mais pas en même temps
pendant le premier confinement se voir
dans un parc était possible jusqu'au 8
février ce sera le cas uniquement pour
ceux qui appartiennent à la même bulle
pas de barrage à prévoir sur les routes
entre les régions mais ses déplacements
doit se limiter au strict nécessaire
quant aux achats en magasin une seule
personne par bull est autorisé dans les
commerces essentiel les autres commerces
ont désormais le droit de vendre leurs
produits mais seulement à distance avec
possibilité de récupérer les articles à
l'extérieur si mathieu prost radio
canada montréal